two years ago today i released a video
that was ostensibly a letter to myself
10 years ago but was really an admission
that my mental health was not good and
in fact hadn't been good for quite some
time specifically i was suffering from
the effects of anxiety and depression
and if you'd like to learn more about my
specific case then i'll leave a link to
that video and all the videos i talk
about down in the description i followed
that up a year later with an update
talking about what i've been doing on my
mental health journey over the past year
and this video which i anticipate will
probably be the last in this mini series
seeks to continue that story what i've
been up to in terms of my mental health
over the past two years my reason for
making these videos is to try and expand
the conversation that we have about
mental health i think society's gotten a
lot better at openly discussing mental
health and people feel that they are
able to
say if they are suffering if they think
that they may be in trouble but what i
think is still lacking is the discussion
after that initial conversation
what happens next therapy medication
talking to medical professionals what
these videos this one and the previous
one are attempting to be is simply a
data point trying to show you what one
person's experience has been like
addressing their mental health over the
previous two years and perhaps you're
watching this as somebody who identifies
with some of the issues that i've
mentioned and you're curious as to what
might happen to you perhaps you're
watching this as somebody aiming to
support a friend or a family member i
hope that these videos give you some
kind of idea on both counts and spoiler
alerts they do feature something of a
happy outcome in this video i basically
want to talk about three things
medication therapy two things that kind
of defined the past year for me but also
some thoughts on trajectory and what
this all kind of means i've talked at
some length in the previous video about
medication but to very briefly summarize
after my initial video two years ago i
went to a gp and was prescribed
sertraline which is a drug that counters
both anxiety and depression and i took
sertraline for about 18 months i'm happy
to say that i am no longer taking
medication i'm happy to no longer be on
medication because whilst it absolutely
worked and it definitely made me less
anxious and it brought up my average
mood incidentally great timing to be
taking that during a global pandemic it
did have some side effects notably it
basically mellowed everything out
something that would have made me very
happy previously just registered
somewhere in the middle of my emotions
and equally something that was meant to
make me very sad would just register in
the middle of my emotions everything was
just sort of reduced to
shades of grey i absolutely think it was
the right decision to go on medication
and it definitely helped me through the
most difficult part of the process of
starting to address my mental health
those initial few months when i had to
answer myself some really difficult
questions i'm very glad that i was on
medication for that but at the same time
i know that it was the right decision to
come off of it because i felt like i
wanted to be myself again and after
stopping taking the medication i had
this wonderful feeling of
i could feel that in kind of intense joy
by watching your favorite movie or
listening to your favorite music and i
remember there was one day when i nearly
cried like three or four times because
stuff was sad and i remember being
really happy that i felt i was capable
of feeling that sad again ultimately
medications function in the arsenal of
dealing with mental health is to deal
with your symptoms it doesn't do
anything more than that it just
mitigates your symptoms and the idea was
always i would take medication until i
didn't need to anymore because the
underlying issues will have been if not
resolved addressed and hopefully
improved which has been happening over
the past year or so with
therapy the term therapy encompasses a
huge number of different practices and
they are all ultimately quite personal
so i am not going to go into huge detail
in terms of what i was dealing with
personally apologies if you came into
this video expecting tea uh i'm not
going to spill it but at any rate in my
case i went through two different kinds
of therapy i went through cbt or
cognitive behavioral therapy and i also
went through psychodynamic therapy cbt
was the therapy that was made available
to me on the nhs after an initial
consultation and personally i didn't
find it particularly useful it's
fantastic that it's made available for
free on the nhs but unfortunately for me
it didn't make much of a blasting impact
cbt is
kind of trying to rewire your brain it's
trying to address how you react to
certain stimuli in certain scenarios and
saying right okay well if this is making
you feel a particular way here's a tool
that will make you feel a different way
and i think for certain people that
would be very useful
again for me personally it didn't really
affect the way that i thought it didn't
really get to the heart of why i felt
the way i felt because of this i took
the decision to find and regularly meet
with a private therapist and i will say
up front that this was not cheap it was
50 pounds a session in my case and i
went to one session a week for four or
five months so you can do the maths on
how much money that cost me but
do i think it was one of the best
investments i've ever made
absolutely
yes i ended up working with a phenomenal
therapist called chris hi chris if
you're watching this he refused to watch
any of my videos whilst we were having
sessions together but he said that as
soon as i ended up moving to bath he was
going to find me on youtube and chris
was trained as a psychodynamicist which
is basically a way of looking at mental
health as a kind of chain of events
rather than another approach like
something like transactional analysis
it's quite similar actually to how i was
trained in atmospheric physics i was
trained as a dynamicist which means
looking at how the earth gets heated by
the sun and warms up and then that heats
the air above it and that air then moves
there's a kind of logical flow
it's a similar kind of thing with
psychodynamics as far as i can
understand the way that our sessions
worked was basically an hour-long
conversation with no particular goal in
mind it's not like we were working to a
syllabus or a timetable or anything and
what that practically meant was for the
first week or two just getting to know
me and what my head is doing at the
moment what the big events in my life
have been but after that inviting me to
talk about something initially and that
could be something that happened to me
that day or it might be something that
i'd mentioned in a previous session and
chris would effectively kind of guide
the conversation but let me speak for
myself and kind of draw my own
conclusions and add his
wisdom you know the information that
he's learned from his training to
my experiences my insights so he would
say for example that oh that sounds like
this person might be an example of a
transitional object and then talking
about what that means and what it's
meant for other people but at no point
was i told this is what this means this
is what your life has been doing it was
very much based on
letting me draw my own conclusions and
kind of letting me come to realizations
myself and this was a very private
process it's something that i didn't
even share with my fiance quite
frequently there were lots of things
that i wanted to keep for myself partly
for privacy but also because they were
so freshly formed in my head that i felt
like i couldn't articulate them yet and
it would take time to just sit in my
brain and feel like i knew
where i'd kind of gotten to what i'd
actually realized in my particular case
the ultimate realization i guess was
that
my anxiety which i think is the root
cause of an awful lot of my issues is
ultimately caused by a fear of
disappointing others
and
that's just something that's been
seared into me for half many years quite
possibly since childhood but recognizing
that process that idea makes a
tremendous difference in modifying my
behavior because ultimately the point of
therapy is to take subconscious
processes and just elevate them to the
conscious it's not actually to change
you it's not to rewire you it's just to
help you recognize
what's going on inside your head and
with that knowledge on with knowing that
you know this is the way my brain works
it modifies how i approach situations
and it has changed my behavior when i'm
in a situation where i'm feeling really
anxious about doing something for
somebody there's a little voice now in
my head that goes wait hang on no no
you're getting anxious because you're
afraid of disappointing them and they
they're not going to be disappointed
like because of these reasons and then
suddenly you know your shoulders untense
and you can you can breathe a little
easier and you just
generally calm down and that for me has
been the impact of therapy as i've
already said this process was expensive
and i am privileged to have been able to
afford it but if you are considering
therapy if you think it might benefit
you if you're on the fence i would
implore you to give it a go and i'd
implore you to find the right therapist
for you so mind which is a great charity
has a fantastic resource online for
finding a therapist near you
i was very lucky in that i actually
found chris on my first try and we just
kind of clicked it was the right person
for me but therapists recognize that you
have to click like that and it might not
be your first or second or third or
tenth therapist so a lot of people will
do a trial appointment and if it doesn't
work it doesn't work they won't be
offended and you can try with somebody
else the important thing is to feel
comfortable with whoever you are seeing
and that may be that you want to see
somebody in person at the moment it may
be that you want to only see somebody
via zoom over the internet whatever it
is that works for you but again if you
can afford it i would highly recommend
therapy it's
changed the trajectory of the rest of my
life which leads me on very neatly to
the last point i wanted to talk about
trajectory something that i think it's
important to understand is that mental
health doesn't have an end point there
is no point at which you are
fixed every single person on earth has
some form of internal struggle with
their emotions but that struggle can be
a minor skirmish from time to time or it
could be all-out war and in my case i
found that over the past two years the
scale of conflict has basically just
decreased it's not completely gone away
there are still days when i feel anxious
there are days when i feel depressed but
comparing the state now to how it was
two years ago there's just no comparison
i feel that i'm more in control of the
way that i feel i feel like i understand
more the way that i feel and i've
changed some of my habits to
force the conflict to de-escalate my
mental health journey isn't over the
past couple of years have basically been
just a chapter in that journey perhaps a
chapter at the end of a section of the
book actually we're now going into the
second part of that story whereas in
that first part i learned some skills
and i got some insight into the way that
my
emotions work the way that my brain
behaves and those insights and those
skills will be incredibly useful to me
and necessary to use for
the rest of my life through therapy i've
learned to elevate some of my
subconscious processes to conscious ones
i've also identified that i stress eat
and try to eat my way out of sadness you
may notice in this triptych videos that
i gained and then lost about 15 kilos i
learned that i previously undervalued
spending time away from my desk with
friends i undervalued time spent just
working on hobbies and reading and doing
exercise but these don't mean that i'm
somehow fixed they just mean that i'm
better equipped to deal with whatever
challenges come at me in the next
section the next part of my mental
health story and that just about wraps
up what i wanted to say in this video i
hope that this video and the previous
videos have been useful to you whether
you are perhaps undergoing a similar
kind of difficulties or if you are
caring for friends or family if you
found this video series and you're going
through a dark time in your life i want
you to know and i do mean you
specifically that
it's going to be all right
that
things pass
and eventually
they will get better
what you can do is to accelerate that
process by taking your mental health
seriously the first step is to
admit to yourself and perhaps to your
friends and to your family that things
aren't so great
the next step
is very individual but these videos have
shown you one possible route talking to
a medical professional taking medication
seeking therapy
and in this particular case
it worked and i went from an incredibly
dark place in my life to
feeling like a new person and feeling
much more content with
who i am
you can do it too
thank you for watching i'll leave links
to resources that you may find useful in
the description
and no matter where you are in your
mental health journey i hope that your
trajectory is curving upwards
that's the only important thing really
thank you for watching i'll see you in
the next one